Despite the challenging times we
I look around this room
and I see people that are hardworking.
Many of you.
I don't even think
you should be working that hard.
We should be inspired
by the events in France.
They rioted
when the retirement age went up
two years to 64
They rioted
because they didn't want to work
Meanwhile, in America,
we have an 80 year old man
begging us for four more years.
Of work
begging,
begging
let me finish the job.
That's not a campaign slogan.
That's a version
of this initiative.
I do.
I do wish you the best of luck
on the campaign trail.
Mr. President,
you got a lot of things
that you're going to have to nav
a lot of hurdles.
You've had quite a few scandals.
You know, we
I know we know about the documen
We know about the laptops,
but there's been no scandal
more damaging than the scandal.
Love. Is Joe Biden awake?
Say what you want about our pres
Look,
when he wake up from that
nap, work gets done.
He might doze off with an infras
bill.
O student loan forgiveness.
Hey, do we free
Brittney Griner, free Brittney G
But I think the most insulting s
to fall
to the feet of the Biden adminis
was place
at the feet of our madam vice pr
The scandal of what does
Camilla do
which is a disrespectful questio
That's a disrespectful question
because nobody ever asked
that question
of the vice president
until a woman got the job
I'm going to ask
I don't know what Mac this be.
The only thing I know about Mike
is that he's really good
at playing hide and seek at the
You've got to be crafty
to catch Mike Pence in.
That kept
hitting the wall of nooks and cr
Don't put the camera on her
and the Mike Pence joke.
Don't do that.
Well,
he said he's trying to set you u
Madam Vice President,
at the end of the day,
as the vice president,
the only thing
only you got to do
is just be better than Dick Chen
That's to
just be better than Dick Cheney.
They made a documentary about Di
Cheney.
Now, I don't know
much about the job of vice presi
but I do know
if they can make a documentary
about your time as vice presiden
you vice president.
It incorrectly
and if a VP VP's job is really
just waiting
to step in to save the country
in case of emergency,
then the job of vice president
is a perfect job for a black wom
Shouldn't be, but it is.
And whatever you do accomplish,
whatever you do accomplish
are you going to do it?
Just give a man credit for
anything you do
all the immigration stuff.
You were knocked out, didn't you
Got all this banking
and you got the Internet down th
You're taking care
of all this postpartum stuff.
They just going to give a man cr
for what you done, by the way.
Mr.
President, great job at being th
first woman vice president
of color.
I don't even know how you did th
Wonderful job.
Happy to be here.
But tonight
tonight is all about you,
all the journalists,
the defenders of free speech,
the people who show truth to the
through different mediums,
through television,
through print, through radio,
through whatever.
Trying to let us see you on Twit
but the industry
that covers all of these scandal
isn't immune to them.
They're self
the issue with the media is that
most people can't afford that.
All the essential, fair
and nuanced reporting,
it's all stuck behind a paywall.
People can't afford rent.
People can't afford food,
not healthy food.
They can't afford an education.
They damn sure
can't afford to pay for the trut
Same as you one
about a conspiracy theory, but a
is affordable
unless you
Alex Jones,
it goes you by not having to mak
and I understand that
we have to put this stuff
behind the paywall
because creating the truth is im
People can't afford the truth,
but you all can afford
to go find the truth.
For free.
The work you do as
journalists is important.
It's essential.
It's dangerous.
My father was an embedded
reporter on the frontlines
with black platoons in Vietnam.
He was in the South African Sowe
He covered that
the civil war in Rhodesia,
which we know today in Zimbabwe.
And my father came back
home and co-founded
the National Black Network
because he wanted to tell black
to American Urban
Radio Networks now,
and they've been doing it for 50
And that's part of what my fathe
wanted to do. You know,
and I know it was
hard because, you know, black
dad is loved
telling you when something was d
They were shooting at me.
Boy, I I never dropped my tape r
my daddy tell war stories
like Brian Williams
Lester Holt didn't laugh at that
Okay. So I don't know
good journalism, cos
that's the truth of the matter.
The journalism cost the people,
but it also cost the journalists
It could even cost you your free
We talked about,
even though The Wall Street Jour
sitting in a Russian prison
as we speak on espionage charges
which espionage charges, by the
That's the foreign equivalent
of saying someone fits the descr
Evan and hundreds of journalists
imprisoned all over the world
simply for doing their job.
We got to defend brave journalis
most national stories in this co
At some point were first a local
and
those stories and
championed by reporters at outle
that many of them have now folde
If we can't figure out a way
to pay local reporters,
then as a country
we're only left
with that many more blind spots
to where the ball is happening.
You hear about all these newsroo
getting cuts.
I see
every article that Tamra's
been sending me in the last two
it's just the newsroom is gettin
cutting people with cutting budg
But you never hear about the mul
dollar executives
reducing their salaries
within these organizations.
Now, how do we fix this
I don't know.
I'm a comedian.
I was just up in
It's not my job to have the solu
That's all y'all.
But local local reporting
is very important.
My mother is here tonight.
And
I know she's furious right now
because I'm trying to put on cam
But my mother was among
a group of black student protest
fighting for equality in the six
At Delta State University and
And
that was a dangerous time.
But those types of incidents
were covered by local reporters.
And some of the shame
that came
from the national embarrassment
of treating people inhumanely.
It's part of the pressure
that helped to create
that type of change.
What would have become of my mot
and those of the protesters
of a local journalist
wasn't there telling the story
And now is no different.
But thankfully,
my mother's story was told
she got to complete a degree
at Delta State
and continued on to Florida.
A&M and got another degree.
And then for the last 45 years,
has worked
at a historically black
colleges and educator
and administrator and
one of those many black colleges
They need a little bit more fund
You've got a 20 on your job
here to send that down
to one of the black colleges.
To my mom I say thank you
for everything you've done for m
and for helping countless studen
in Birmingham have the opportuni
to see a college degree
and to see an opportunity to gro
You know,
my mother's journey
may not have even begun
if not for brave journalists
who chose to chronicle
history in real time.
And I don't know how to ever rep
for what she's done for me
and what she's done
for so many people in Alabama.
But just know, Mama, if
if a white billionaire call
you an offer to buy your
house, please sell it
because I might want to become a
Thank you so much.
So the Correspondents Associatio
Tamara Keith, thank you all so m
For Night